[Música]
y
tenía tan solo 10 años cuando empecé a
descubrir que algo no funcionaba bien en
mí me ayudaban las manos
tenía miedo cuando llegaban las tías y
tenía que esconderme en la habitación no
lograba tener amigos hasta que más o
menos de los once años descubrí que eso
lo llamaban fobia social y que me
impedía relacionarme aún queriendo
generar vínculos hacia los 12 años
entonces encontré que si consumía
alcohol desaparecía mi sudoración de
manos ya no tenía vergüenza ni tenía
miedo a que se burlaran de minya que me
ridiculizar a entonces me aferré al
alcohol con fuerza y fue a los 13 que
descubrí que si consumía cocaína
entonces el efecto del alcohol no era
tan contundente y no me la pasaba ebrio
en la vida motivo por el cual hacia los
18 años terminé en un centro de
rehabilitación para adictos a los 19
años pensé entonces que todo estaba
resuelto ya no era tan tímido ya no
había esta ansiedad tan fuerte ya no
consumía drogas pero pasaba algo muy
raro durante los siguientes ocho años
empecé a notar que dividía el mundo
entre los buenos y los malos los
inteligentes y los tontos los que sabían
y los que no sabían llevaban listados
dependientes desglosados en 1.1.1 1.1.2
1.1 punto 3 practicando el check list
para sentir que si podía y que era
suficiente odiaba la injusticia trataba
de educar a todo el planeta trataba que
jamás pudiese cometer un error o
equivocarme anulando toda la
espontaneidad ya estaba estudiando
psicología así es que pronto me di
cuenta que existía algo que se conocía
como trastorno de la personalidad
obsesiva
pero fue después de 8 años hacia los 27
años en mi primera clase doctoral cuando
empecé a mirar a todo el mundo ya
decirme ellos saben más que yo se van a
dar cuenta que me infiltré sin tener el
nivel para poder estar aquí pronto van a
descubrir que soy una farsa y empecé a
respirar raro y aparecieron cosas que
llevaba experimentando durante 8
me dolía la mandíbula del bruxismo tenía
contracturas musculares tenía una
arritmia cardíaca muy fuerte que
apareció en esa mesa doctoral y empecé a
sentir que me iba a infartar y empecé a
respirar mal y me desmayé tuve entonces
mi primer ataque de pánico ese día me di
cuenta que esto iba mucho más allá y que
había que trabajar en profundidad
apareció el yoga apareció la meditación
apareció la psicoterapia apareció la
salud mental el ejercicio y de los 29
años en adelante viene una época
maravillosa sin ansiedad sin rigideces
estando suelto disfrutando la vida pero
a los 40 años
sucedió algo muy fuerte todo marchaba
bien pero el destino me jugó una mala
pasada aparecieron extorsiones
aparecieron robos aparecieron traiciones
y empecé a sentir un dolor en la mitad
del pecho como si alguien introdujera su
mano allí me dolía el cuero cabelludo
dormía dos horas tres horas a veces
pasaban dos o tres días sin dormir
lloraba todos los
pero en ese momento tenía el
entrenamiento suficiente para saber que
tenía una depresión después de 40 años
por primera vez en mi vida entendí que
era sentirse deprimido
cuando estaba pensando en esto que
quería plantearles empecé a preguntarme
por qué en una historia de ansiedad de
adicciones y depresión
habían unas cosas distintas en mí por
ejemplo empecé a preguntarme porque yo
era alguien que no había sido del grupo
del millón y medio de personas que se
suicidó en el planeta entre el 2018 y el
2019 si mis problemas más serios
estuvieron entre los 15 y los 29 años
etapa en el mundo que es la segunda
causa de muerte por suicidio
empecé a preguntarme por qué podría ser
exitoso laboralmente cuando el 34% de
los años de vida laboral perdidos en las
américas se deben a trastornos de salud
mental empecé a preguntarme por qué no
tenía cáncer o una enfermedad
cardiovascular o diabetes cuando muchos
de los trastornos mentales inciden
directamente en que aparezcan estas
enfermedades o porque yo no tenía un
tema de ansiedad cuando en el mundo el
36 por ciento de la población tiene un
problema de ansiedad y si vives en un
país como colombia es el 5,8 por ciento
lo que quiere decir que en este momento
mientras estamos viendo este ted hay
2.700.000 colombianos con un problema de
ansiedad o porque no estaba deprimido si
es que el 4.4 por ciento de la población
mundial está en ese estado en colombia
es el 47 por ciento estamos hablando de
2 millones 200 mil colombianos que están
en ese estado o porque viviendo en un
país como el nuestro donde el 11,9 por
ciento de los niños el 29 3% de los
adolescentes y el 41% de los adultos ha
vivido un evento traumático porque
habiendo crecido en medio de bombas
extorsiones y cosas difíciles no tenía
estrés postraumático
y entendí que básicamente se debía a
tres razones
número uno
tenía el conocimiento suficiente para
saber que sin salud mental no hay salud
y que un problema de salud mental no te
hace tonto no te hace débil lo que hace
ignorante y que ir al psicólogo o ir al
psiquiatra no te convierte en ello y que
además ni la ansiedad ni la depresión
son posesiones demoníacas maldeojo
brujería pereza o falta de voluntad son
temas realmente serios también porque
fui a aquellos que pude ser parte del
10% que accede a un servicio de salud
mental no a citas de 20 o 30 minutos oa
citas que te dan después de muchas
semanas cuando ya puede ser tarde y
porque además tenía el entrenamiento
para reconocer los síntomas que hacen
que pudiese saber que necesitaba ayuda
pero qué hacemos con todas las personas
que no tienen ese conocimiento que no
tienen esa información que no sabrían
cómo actuar y que hacen parte de los
diferentes grupos que se consideran de
mayor riesgo seguramente aquellos grupos
minoritarios niños que han sido
expuestos a violencia abandono maltrato
a adolescentes expuestos a drogas
personas que han vivido la
discriminación pues podríamos decir que
son personas que tendrían mayor riesgo
pero saben algo más allá de eso a veces
quien no deja de dormir por exceso de
trabajo o quien no se deprime en medio
de sus pérdidas o de sus duelos o quien
no se siente tenso y aumenta su
agresividad en medio de las dificultades
que plantea la vida esto no es un tema
de grupos minoritarios esto es un tema
humano en el 2019 se escribieron se
publicaron
65.000 artículos de salud mental hoy
sabemos cómo resolver esto pero cuando
nos preguntamos por qué teniendo tanto
conocimiento nos invierte lo suficiente
nos encontramos con que al parecer las
heridas de la salud mental al no ser
visibles son tratadas como
circunstancias de segunda categoría o de
segunda clase pero preguntémonos lo
siguiente
qué tan herida o qué tan mal puede estar
una mujer que abraza a su hijo y decide
votarse por un puente mientras todo el
mundo la filma y se transmite en cadena
nacional aunque su niño le suplicaba que
no saltara como vimos hace un tiempo en
nuestro país que tan mal puede estar un
hombre que mata a sus hijos mata a su
esposa y después se suicida
si nosotros pensamos que la salud mental
no es un tema serio la respuesta a la
pregunta porque en el grueso de los
países difícilmente superamos el 2% del
presupuesto de salud asignado a salud
mental pues entendemos que es por esa
percepción que tenemos pues bien en este
contexto que podríamos hacer qué
podríamos hacer con las cifras que
tenemos que podríamos hacer con la
cantidad de personas que necesitan algún
tipo de abordaje que sea efectivo pues
vamos a pensar en cuatro caminos
camino número uno es muy difícil pedir
ayuda es muy difícil acceder a un
servicio cuando tienes una serie de
estigmas que hacen que sea vergonzoso
pensar que tienes un tema de salud
mental así es que lo primero que hay que
hacer es que necesitamos de forma masiva
atacar y derrumbar el estigma utilizando
todos los medios que podamos utilizar
para lograrlo número 2 es imposible
abordar las cifras que tenemos
apostándole a una salud mental
individualizada en un yo uno a uno
incluso con las formaciones que tenemos
del personal de salud mental va a ser
muy difícil que lo logremos a menos que
demos un viraje y saquemos la salud
mental de los consultorios y de los
centros y no la llevemos a las
comunidades a centros comunitarios donde
la prevención y la promoción sea lo que
reine donde el abordaje de los problemas
leves y moderados se puede hacer a
través de dinámicas grupales que
disminuyen los costos y permiten un
mayor acceso de la población dejando los
temas crónicos a las especialidades más
fuertes número 3 si queremos realmente
hacer algo masivo nos toca apostarle al
surgimiento de la ciberpsicología que ya
en el mundo están dando soluciones que
puedan ser asincrónicas que puedan ser
exponenciales y que garanticen que se
pueda democratizar la salud mental y
número 4 necesitamos cuidar al cuidador
porque no puede ser que el cuidador
tenga mayor estrés
que en casos como la medicina se
duplique el riesgo del suicidio
si nosotros le apostamos a esto le
invertimos a esto nos soñamos con que
esto sea viable vamos a poder alcanzar
algo que me gusta llamar el bien
colateral el bien colateral quiere decir
que cuando tú ayudas a una madre cabeza
de familia no estás ayudando solamente
esta mujer sino el efecto que ya tienen
sus hijos y esos hijos más felices
tienen un profesor en la escuela que al
ver la felicidad de sus alumnos dotar a
su trabajo de mayor sentido y ese
maestro tiene una familia que al ver la
felicidad de ese padre y la manera
distinta de conectarse sentirá cosas y
cuando vaya al tendero que está en la
esquina tendrá un trato diferente de tal
manera que es como una piedra que cae en
un lago y genera ondas expansivas de tal
suerte que la frase del talmud se haga
realidad cuando salvas un alma salva su
universo completo muchas gracias
[Música]